الاعتراضية والدفاعات الجوية.
والاهم من ذلك كله هو كمبيوتر
سرعة الصوت. اثنين مع تشويش
الكتروني دفاعي ضد المقاتلات
الروسية عن باقي القاذفات
الاخرى. تم تطويرها سابقا لتكون
نعم يا اصدقاء انها القاذفة
الحربية والنووية في الوقت ذاته
الروسية ضد الاساطيل الغربية. هي
قاذفة خارقة للعادة. جاءت من عمق
الحروب القديمة لتسيطر على
الحروب الجديدة وبين الماضي
ونسختها النووية ايضا صواريخ ما
جعلها احد الحلول التكتيكية
قنبلة حرة التوجيه وحمل نوعين من
الصواريخ الفرض صوتية من طراز
ارتفاع عال او الهجوم بشكل منخفض
بسرعة فائقة. تصل سرعتها لضعف
خاصة في المهام الهجومية بسبب
امكانيات الطيران الممتازة على
والحاضر سيطرت الة القتل الروسية
الفتاكة على الحروب والمعارك.
كيلومتر. الطائرة فعلا هي احد
الرؤوس بسلاح الجو الروسي فهي
وسبعة الاف كيلومتر مع مدى قتالي
يصل الى اكثر من الفين واربعمائة
حلا مرنا يسهل اعادة تموضعه باي
مكان بفاعلية قتالية غير عادية.
اكثر القاذفات الاستراتيجية
تواجدا بمسارح العمليات العسكرية
هذا كله? مهلا مهلا مهلا. بوليف
تحلق على ارتفاع ثلاثة عشر الف
معدات استطلاع واستشعار بينها
رادار جانبي ومعدات تشويش
مائة واثنى عشر الف كيلو جرام.
فضلا عن ان المدى العملياتي
قدم. بسرعة تصل الى اكثر من
الفين وثلاثمائة كيلو متر في
التنشين في توجيه القنابل. لنوضح
قليلا. قادرة على حمل نحو ستين
لاستخدامها ضد المدرعات والاهداف
الحصينة الخفيفة والافراد. لتصيب
الساعة وزنها فارغا ثمانية
وخمسون الف كيلو جرام. وبالحمولة
المتطورة هي قادرة على حمل عشرة
صواريخ متنوعة الطرز والاحجام
جميع انواع الاهداف دون تفريق.
تتميز بالاقلاع القصير بالكفاءة
في التحليق بالسرعة العالية
وبالطيران المنخفض. وماذا بعد
ومن الجو ستسيطر بسهولة على البر
والبحر. تم صناعة مع خاصية
التزود بالوقود بالجو عبر خرطوم
في الجزء العلوي من المقدمة توفر
الغربي ويا له من تعزيز جعل
روسيا تسيطر على المعارك الجوية
قاذفة استراتيجية فعالة وموثوقة
بشكل كبير. ومن يكذب فليجرب اولم
الجوية الروسية شهرة لتميزها على
مدى ثلاثة من الخدمة باعتبارها
الكاسر. نشأة ومميزاتها. صنعتها
شركة الروسية التي تأسست قبل مئة
عام. فعن اي عراقة نتحدث ليعزز
الترسانة الجوية لمواجهة المعسكر
تشرح جميع الحروب السابقة
مواصفات هذا الوحش الروسي
الخبراء فيعتبر ناتوفوليفت ونيتو
ام ثري احد اكثر رموز القوة
تاريخ عتيق للمقاتلة المخضرمة ما
بين الحروب القديمة والجديدة
بالثانية والذي اطلق من توجوليف
ان يفتح في جسم حاملة الطائرات
المخيفة لقب مفترسة السفن وقاتلة
حاملات الطائرات. فخلال احدى
التجارب السابقة استطاع صاروخ
المجنح الاسرع من الصوت الذي
لتصبح ملكة للاجواء اينما حلت.
يطلق العسكريون على هذه الطائرة
يستطيع قطع مسافة تصل الى
خمسمائة كيلومتر بسرعة الف متر
افغانستان وحربي الشيشان خلال
تسعينيات القرن العشرين وحرب
من الصواريخ الاخرى. او وحش
الحرب الباردة شاركت في حرب
جورجيا عام الفين وثمانية والحرب
تتعدد الحروب والفتاكة واحدة
للقاذفة التي دخلت الخدمة
العسكرية قبل ستين عاما. لتكون
فتحة بقطر عشرين مترا لقد بثت
الرعب برا وبحرا وجوا. اما
مماثلة لقاذفات والامريكية.
تستطيع حمل صواريخ كروز والعديد
اوروبا والساحل الشرقي للولايات
المتحدة ضمن نطاق هي امتداد
يبلغ مدى هذه المقاتلة حوالي
سبعة الاف كيلو متر. ما يضع
بعد. تستطيع الاكثر فتكا حمل
قنابل نووية لالاف الكيلومترات
الناتو حال اندلاع الحرب كما
يرون. الصفات المرعبة لم تبدأ
موسكو الخارقة فهي الة الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين المخصصة لتدمير
يتفرج على عظمة الصناعة الروسية.
اشاد الغربيون بقدرات قاذفة
بسرعة تفوق سرعة الصوت. توجد
منها طرز مختلفة واللي ما يشتري
والقاء ما يصل الى اربعة وعشرين
طنا من القنابل. مدمرة شاملة.
باك فاير لاستهداف الاساطيل
البحرية المعاد خلال الحرب
الاتفاقيات ليخسر الاوكران سلاحا
كان لينقذهم من بطش الضربات
القاذفة النووية الاستراتيجية
المعروفة لدى حلف الناتو باسم
الروسية اليوم. قدرات خارقة.
قاذفة جوية روسية صممت هذه
حظها ومع انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي تم تدميرها وفقا لاحدى
غريبة. اوكرانيا كانت قد ورثت
عددا كبيرا من قاذفات لكن لسوء
الاحتفال المعتاد بيوم النصر.
لكن دعوني اخبركم عن مفارقة
في اي مكان في القارة الاوروبية.
وها هو بوتين يستعرض تلك القاذفة
الباردة. لها قوة تدميرية هائلة
وقدرة على الطيران بعيد المدى
الملقبة بمفترسة السفن في الساحة
الحمراء في السابع من مايو خلال
الناتو وتوجيه هجمات نووية بل
وهجمات بعشرات القنابل الحرارية
قاذفات جوية عابرة للقارات اسرع
من الصوت القادرة خرق اجواء حلف
باعدائه واي بطش هذا الذي تمتلكه
الة القتل الروسية الفتاكة انها
الهجمات الروسية ادخل الرئيس
الروسي يده الجوية الباطشة
علم بهذا السلاح الذي ينتظره
انها قاذفة الروسية. وخلال اقل
في الاراضي الاوكرانية لها قوة
تدميرية هائلة وهي اسرع من
من عشرين عاما من تصنيعها كانت
حوالي خمسمائة طائرة من جاهزة في
الصوت. عن المقاتلة نتحدث وللقصة
بقية. من هنا بدأ وحش الجو
مسرح روسيا الجوي عدد مهول من
الطائرات لكن ليس اليوم بل قبل
الروسي قصته. عام الف وتسعمائة
وثمانين دخل وحش كاسر في سلاح
ثلاثين عاما. مع بدء بوتين حربه
في اوكرانيا. وبعد مضي فترة من
الجو الروسي بعد سبع سنوات من
بداية صناعته. لم يكن العالم على
الامريكية ذراع روسيا الباطشة
برا وبحرا وجوا. قادرة على خرق
اجواء حلف شمال الاطلسي واي مكان
في اوروبا ان تسمع صوتها او تشعر
بوجودها. ها هو بوتين اليوم ينفض
الغبار عن محركاتها لتصنع زلزالا
الحروب الباردة. انها مفترسة
السفن وقاتلة حاملات الطائرات
يختبئ في كبد السحاب. قاذفة
الموت الابيض المخيفة وسيدة
الة القتل الفتاكة التي لا تترك
دليل. هي وحش من وحوش بوتين
الروسية. اليكم المصادر.